es un funeral digno de un monarca como
el de la Reina Isabel 2 al que acabamos
de asistir porque en cierto modo Brasil
está despidiendo a su Rey un funeral que
él había querido que fuera Público
simpatizantes de todo el país pudieron
aplaudir sus restos en el corazón del
estadio del Santos durante 24 horas el
mismo presidente Lula visitó el lugar
esta mañana para despedir a este artista
del gol un hombre negro dijo de un
Barrio pobre que fue Coronado como
tesoro nacional y que se codeó con los
más grandes pero que se mantuvo Modesto
y modelo para muchas generaciones de
brasileños son estas generaciones padres
hijos nietos de todo el país que
acompañaron sus restos en una procesión
por la ciudad cantando y aplaudiendo
mientras el ataúd era colocado en un
camión de bomberos a este cementerio
para una ceremonia privada a la que solo
asisten sus familiares más cercanos fue
el mismo Pelé el que eligió que así
fuera porque su padre su hermano y uno
de sus hijos están enterrados aquí en el
piso nueve con Vista a la ciudad y al
estadio Santos pero en su caso su tumba
estará unos pisos más abajo para que sus
fanáticos puedan visitarlo este
cementerio ahora transformado en un
momento en un monumento histórico un
lugar de peregrinación para aficionados
de todo el mundo que quieren visitar al
rey Pelé